so things are beginning to roll I'm back
at Wilde Sun in this amazing studio with
mirrors show them the mirrors and I've
got somebody here for three weeks and
we're playing boy almost every day and
all the inspiration from Leviathan is
beginning to come back so I'm working on
mastering those triquetra Buzz top
flowers and the in spin version and some
things like this which I didn't show you
before the mashup of a triquetra
sideways in one hand meets a one in the
other its rhythmically goes together but
it makes this very weird looking I don't
know you know
these feel amazing and look cool and
this is I think one of my favorite
patterns ever now that it's rolling and
this is just weird curiosity so more
videos are becoming thank you for being
patient it's nice here